Everybody is talking about how terribly important
innovation
is. People are defining innovation. i think
the best
taxonomy of innovation I have seen is a paper
that's about
five years old now, if you are curious about
breaking
innovation down into its components, there
is a paper called
Darwin and the Demon by Geoffrey Moore which
essentially a
taxonomy of innovation, and it tells you - it
describes and
breaks innovation down into topics like service
innovation,
business process innovation, product innovation
and so on.
And the fundamental message you might imagine
is the type of
innovation you work on is less important than
the fact that
you are really, really good at that type of
innovation and
if it's consistent with your company's key
business and
strategic initiatives, right. People tend
to think of Apple
as sort of the pinnacle of innovation. Arguably,
they are
just one type of innovation, and that is product
innovation.
So everybody is talking about what innovation
is. It's
always good to start with definitions. For
the purpose of
this discussion, innovation is creation resulting
from study
and experimentation, and I want to make a
distinction here.
If you come over the cute idea, you put it
on the Wiki, you
throw it in a virtual suggestion box somewhere,
it might be
very creative, it might be cute, it might
clever, but it's
not innovation. For legitimate innovation,
you need some
sort of instantiation of the idea, whether
it's a sketch or
storyboard related to some new service you
are thinking of,
or a simple prototype of what you have created,
or a
physical layout, or some new space that you
are thinking
about. You need to have some sort of instantiation
for your
creative idea in order to actually foster
innovation. What I
want to talk about over the next hour and
I want to hear
from you about when I introduce some of the
ideas is some
specific methods to foster a culture of innovation
in your
organization. That is, I want to talk about
the 'how' rather
than the 'what' or the 'why'. First, let me
just give you
one background slide. I am Director of Technology
Strategy
at IDO. We are a - just so that you understand
where I am
coming from and what my perspective is, we
are professional
services firm, about 20 years old now. I joined
actually
when the company had just been created as
a result of a
merger with three other firms. And our exclusive
mission
statement is that we help our clients to innovate
as a
professional services firm, and we do that
by taking a
human-centered approach to design of products
and services
and experiences. People pay us to do three
things. People
pay us to gain insights into populations of
stakeholders.
They might be internal people of an organization;
they might
be external customers. For example, one of
my projects now
has to do with better understanding the needs
of home PC
users in China. Second, people pay us to visualize
solutions, opportunities and solutions based
on the
inspiration that comes from that field of
research. And
third, people pay us to help them redesign
their
organization using methods of design thinking
to help them
foster more sustainable cultures of innovation.
So, in
preparing this, what David and I agreed would
be most
interesting are to highlight some of the methods
of what we
like to call Design Thinking and the power
of designing
thinking to drive innovation in an organization.
What's the
big idea with design thinking? There are any
number of ways
to innovate; there are any number of ways
to be creative.
One way to do that is to look at some of the
most creative
professions in the world that are applied.
Look at
advertising, look at architecture, look at
industrial design
and ask yourself "What are some of the mental
constructs
that these people have? How do they think?
How do they
experience the world?" And then, to roll those
approaches,
those behaviors that some of the most creative
people have
into a set of principles that we call Design
Thinking. And
that's what I want to talk about to you this
afternoon.
What's design thinking all about? Design thinking
is about
creating the right kind of interdisciplinary
teams of what
we call t-shaped people - we will get to that
in a minute.
That's one of the key points that I want to
make this
morning. The second key thing that I want
to emphasize is
the second area around design thinking, which
is to observe
to become inspired and to synthesize observations,
sticking
up with actionable observations, actionable
opportunities.
The third principle of design thinking is
to use your
inspiration gained from the field to visualize
new
opportunities. And the fourth is to make appropriate
use of
prototypes, and I am going to define prototypes
for you, to
help drive forward the innovation process.
So we will go
into each of these in detail but I want to
make a very key
point here, and I think it was mentioned in
the blurb that
summarize this talk. What's the subtext here?
Okay, I am
talking about how to be creative, how to be
innovative up
here. The subtext here is innovation is absolutely
not some
innate talent that people either have or they
don't1. That's
this old archaic way of thinking about innovation
and
creativity, and I urge you to reject it. I
completely reject
that notion. Innovation is absolutely a learnable
skill. As
with any other skill, like playing piano or
learning
mathematics, different people appear to have
different
levels of innate aptitudes towards creativity.
I know a guy
who is a VC and has like a new idea, and it's
a pretty good
idea like every eight minutes. I call it the
Carter timer
because just like Carter has these new ideas
constantly.
That's great. The key point I want to make
is anyone can
learn the team-based sport of innovation.
How many of you
worked with advertising firms? This is old
archaic notion in
many advertising firms, especially if you
like to watch Mad
Men, something like that, still
[inaudible]. The term 'creative' is a noun.
Have you guys
swerved into this? They use the word 'creative'
to describe
these people in backrooms on Madison Avenue.
You never
really meet. They have got weird shoes and
messed up hair
and stuff like that. And you meet the well-groomed
account
manager in an accounting firm. I see some
people nodding,
you have been through this. And the premise
there is the
creatives are people that you can't possibly
be, and they
are locked away because they have something
you don't.
Reject that. It's bunk. I have been in this
field for 20
years. I can tell you these are learnable
skills. How do you
learn them? What do you do? Step one, assemble
the right
team. Assemble an innovation team that is
both
interdisciplinary, and foster the creation
t-shaped people.
Let's take those things in reverse order.
What's a t-shaped
person? A a-shaped person - and we use the
metaphor of a 't'
literally - a t-shaped person is someone who
has a depth of
expertise. No nothing middle managers are
gone, they
disappeared in the 80s. You need to know something.
You are
deep in accounting; you are deep in finance;
you are all
about engineering; you are electrical engineer;
you are
software engineer; you are a chip designer.
You know
something. You have got a depth of expertise
that is your
path to move upwards into the professional
world. What's the
legality? The legality is not being all things
to all
people. The legality is honest appreciation
and empathy for
the other disciplines. So I am talking here
about a software
engineer who is really, really good at writing
code but has
an honest appreciation for example of the
needs and the
motivations of a marketing person and a salesperson
and a
quality engineer. When you are hiring, and
when you are
growing talent as leaders in Silicon Valley
or elsewhere,
when you are interviewing, look for people
that use the
pronoun 'we' more than they use the pronoun
'I'. Look for
people who are proud of their achievements
primarily by
highlighting their own contributions as part
of a team of
people that they are really proud of. That's
an early
indicator that you are looking at a t-shaped
individual. You
will not get much in a way of innovation from
people who
talk about how smart they are, and they might
be super smart
and sort of suddenly devalue the contributions
of other
people that were around them on the team or
their boss or
something like that. So, this sort of t-shaped
behavior is
really essential for successful innovation
teams. I spend a
lot of time working with David. David fundamentally
had a
program that he and I worked together last
summer. He was
fundamentally the business guy in a program.
We will talk
more about that in a minute. But the fact
that he had an
honest appreciation for the needs of the manufacturing
engineers who were worried about the cost
of the product
that he put out. So it's depth of expertise
in an area, and
what I would call an honest and sincere empathy
for other
domains that are outside your own, that could
be cultivated
in people, that can also be looked for in
the hiring
process. So, what do we recommend for an innovation
team?
You want to do something innovative. You are
thinking about
next generation data services for smartphones.
You are
thinking about some really new exciting renewable
energy
programs. You are thinking about fostering
products to
decrease the cost of health care. There are
just a
tremendous number of wonderful domains that
I am sure you
are either in or will be moving into when
you graduate that
are exciting and it will all call for tremendous
innovation,
little hard to read. Let me talk you through
the text here.
I submit that in early stages for innovation,
you need three
voices on an innovation team, and those voices
come from t-
shaped people who are open ultimately to unifying
into a
single voice and a single direction. There
are people who
have strong points of view themselves but
appreciate the
existence of other people's point of view.
So what have we
got? We have got the voice of business and
business
viability, the voice of technology and the
voice of the
human, the voice of the stakeholder, either
the end customer
or the person somewhere else in the supply
chain who is an
important stakeholder in the business or policy
success of
your endeavor. Let's talk about each of those.
Let's talk
about business briefly, and then one of the
things that
David recommended that we talk in some detail
about how as
business leaders, you can manage technical
people to help
foster innovation in highly technical organizations.
But
let's start with business. What is the role
of a
businessperson on an innovation team? Before
we are getting
into the details of implementation, before
we are into sort
of classic product management areas of rollout
and so on, a
businessperson - and a lot of you may play
this role, those
of you that are still in school may play this
role in the
future - a businessperson does two things
on an innovation
team. First of all, a businessperson helps
acquaint every
single person on an innovation team - and
for small
innovation team, we are often talking 3 to
10 people - helps
acquaint and familiarize everyone adequately
with the
business landscape around the innovation challenge
that you
are facing. And this leads to the second myth
buster
statement I want to make which is that there
is this myth
that innovation thrives in, what is called,
the Greenfield
absent any boundaries. That's just wrong,
and that's another
notion that you should reject if you have
ever heard it.
Innovation thrives on constraints, and this
goes to a topic
that you mentioned a little earlier. Some
of the most
constrained cultures, and indeed constrained
businesses,
tiny broke startups with hardly any money,
there are
cultures. India is one of the - we are opening
up office in
Mumbai. We are seeing some of the most impressive
creativity
and innovation coming out of India that I
have ever seen in
my entire life. And a lot of that has to do
with scarcities
in India driving really exciting innovation.
It has to do
with energy scarcity, and resource scarcity,
and capital
market scarcity, and so on. So keep in mind
that in general,
boundaries and constraints and limits are
the friend of
innovation. They help drive innovation. Any
program, from
the outset, should be operating under a clear
set of
boundaries and constraints from a businessperson
on the
current business landscape. Everybody in an
innovation team
should understand things like current market
segmentation,
and the competitive landscape, and the pricing
and costing
models, and the ultimate marketing plan. So
David, on our
program, part of his role was to act as an
ambassador to the
IDO team helping everybody develop the sort
of shared
conversions around business issues. The other
role that a
businessperson plays on many innovation teams,
depending on
the nature of what you are doing, is acting
as a strategic
advisor to the external partners that you
are working with.
So again, using the project that was related
to crafting,
the home crafting market, that David and I
worked on over
the summer. David also acted as a strategic
advisor to our
client building some quantitative spreadsheets
to help
better understand the potential of the proposals
we were
coming up with as compared to their existing
product line.
So, that's what - I mean in brief, we could
talk about this
for hours, all afternoon - but in brief, that's
what a
businessperson does. The inward facing role
of a
businessperson is to help familiarize everybody
on an
interdisciplinary team with business issues.
The outward
facing role is to act as a strategic advisor
to partners as
appropriate. Now, let's talk in little more
detail about
technologists on innovation teams. This is
something that
David and I agreed would be an interesting
thing to cover.
It's very likely that all of you will be in
a position of
managing technologists and wanting to gain
maximum value
from technologists, engineers, scientists,
technicians on
innovation programs. I want to make a couple
of points here.
The first is, I would like to draw a distinction
between
technology push and technology pull. And just
to cut to the
chase, I submit that the winners - and this
has been
consistent, this is one of the few consistent
things over
the 20 years I have had at IDO, so much has
changed -
consistently, the winners are the ones who
create a healthy
tension between technology push and technology
pull and
consider both simultaneously. What does that
mean in a
little more detail? Technology push is a philosophy
which
says, let's take our existing assets, let's
take our
intellectual property, let's take technology
that we have
developed, and let's understand new domains
of opportunity
for that technology, let's identify new areas
around the
globe, new geographic regions that might be
interested, let'
s identify new vertical markets where we might
apply that
technology, let's identify new scenarios of
use. This is an
incredibly important and viable business model
in and of
itself in isolation.
[Informal Talk]
So Professor Andrew
[inaudible] sees tech push as core to the
majority if not
all of the text startups coming out of Silicon
Valley. My
personal poster child for technology push
is Qualcomm. Some
of you may have worked with them. They are
a telecom company
based out of San Diego. They have fantastic
technologies.
One is called CDMA, it's a wireless protocol.
Qualcomm said
to themselves, we have got this fantastic
wireless protocol,
let's push it into new domains. We are starting
to saturate
the United States, let's push into Korea,
let's push into
China. We are starting to saturate the telecom
market in
general, let's push into new vertical markets,
let's push
into medical instruments and devices, body
worn devices like
cardiac monitors that broadcast their telemetry
back to
mission control centers. It's been a hugely
successful model
for them. Now, let's contrast tech push with
technology
pull. Technology pull says, let's forget about
technology,
let's forget about what we own. Let's put
business models
and human beings at the center of our thinking.
And let's
think about important and relevant trends,
demographic,
economic, social, political, religious. Let's
think about
important emerging trends, and let's ask ourselves
what
technology might be brought to bear on those
trends that is
relevant. Or more typically, what aggregation
of technology
might be brought to bear on those trends that
is relevant to
this fundamental consumer demand, this fundamental
human
need. Poster child here, longtime client of
IDO's, Procter &
Gamble. So they employ thousands of scientists
but they don'
t typically start with a given science with
a given
technology that they have developed, like
a chemical
formulation, and explore how to apply it.
They typically
start with fundamental human needs like people
hate ironing
or people want their clothes to last longer,
and they ask
themselves what technology can be brought
to bear. So, the
interesting thing is if you go back and look
at my two
poster children for these two trends, what's
Qualcomm doing?
Qualcomm is making a very hard move into technology
pull.
Qualcomm is hiring market researchers and
anthropologists
and human factors people like crazy in order
to better
understand some of the global social and economic
trends,
and they are coming up with a philosophy that
includes
organic development of technology, licensing
and outsourced
technology development with a view towards
increasing their
quotient around technology pull. And similarly,
Procter &
Gamble, right about the time I started working
with them
which is about 12 years ago, they are moving
this way. They
had developed a certain technology for de-wrinkling
governments, and they said to them - and what
they
essentially said to IDO was where else can
this technology
be applied, how can we push this technology
to new domains
and maximize the investment that we have already
put into
this technology. So, let me just show you
a couple of
examples of technology pull that I think are
significant.
All of you have probably seen technology push.
What's hot
these days? There is a technology that you
have probably
heard about. If not, you will call Near Field
Communication,
NFC. This is an important enabling technology
for
transactions and mobile commerce, typically
from a cell
phone, for the mobile phone. So, that sort
of technology
lends itself to say, okay, there is an existing
Near Field
Communication technology, one of them for
example is called
Sony FeliCa. What else can we do with it?
What else can be
pushed? Good viable way to look at the world.
The first
example I want to bring up for tech pull is
entirely new
mental models of authority and expertise.
I am older than a
lot of you guys, and I can tell you that the
mental
constructs that the world has around authority
and expertise
have been turned on their head in the last
15 years,
something that sociologists and historians
are going to be
studying forever. Traditional models of authority,
doctors,
ministers, consumer reports, magazines, on
losing power in
favor of bottoms up/ground up authority from
Wikis and
blogs, and crowdsourcing. I mean my God, look
what's
happened in Egypt, if anybody more than two
weeks ago had
any doubt about the importance of the inversion
of
authority. Look at some of these examples,
public
commissioning investigative reports on Spot.Us,
live
broadcast from mobile web phones, a TV station
based
entirely on user-created content. So this
is not a
technology like a Wiki or a blog or something
like this.
This is a fundamental human trend, and it
is incumbent on us
to ask ourselves all right, what technology
could be brought
to bear by my organization or by the startup
I am creating
or whatever to address this important trend.
Another
example, all the worlds are pointer. This
is not a
technology, it's a trend, it's a new mental
construct. It's
a technology-driven construct because that's
what I
specialize in, and we could talk about non-technology-driven
constructs. People are expecting - they wouldn't
put it to
you this way - but people are expecting a
virtual overlay to
the physical world, and it's been fascinating
for me to
watch this grow. 10 years ago, this thing
called Yellow
Arrow was really huge, and we all thought
it was just
amazing and very, very cool. I mean 10 years
just seems to
fly by. But the state of the art of augmented
reality 10
years ago was people would slap these yellow
arrow stickers
like in front of historic buildings in New
York. You would
text message the serial number, the unique
serial number on
that yellow arrow into the yellow arrow company,
and you
would get a text message back which allowed
you to read in
just straight text about what you were looking
at. Now, 10
years later, we have got things like Google
Goggles that
allows you to actually hold your phone up
in front of
something and see a virtual overlay to the
physical world,
like the ratings of a given restaurant or
something like
that. Much of this is enabled by Cloud computing.
So here
again, why we bring this up? We bring this
up because this
is an important technology pull mental construct.
People are
going to start to think of physical objects
as tags and
pointers to cyber space. That's a very important
trend and
it's only going to increase. Everybody is
thinking about
this. I am working with State Farm Insurance
right now, we
spend a lot of our time on my current project
thinking about
the previous trend I described to you which
is the notion of
what happens to the insurance business in
an era in which
authority is inverted and access to information,
like
actuarial tables, has become completely democratized.
I want
to pause there because that's the first major
thing I wanted
to talk about was this. Well, let me just
say a few more
words about tech push and tech pull just to
sum up. So what
are we talking about here? We are talking
about managing
technologists, and we are talking about managing
engineers
and how engineers need to behave on innovation
programs. And
so again, the first point I want to make here
is that one
job of an engineer or a technologist managed
by a
businessperson, which most of you are, is
to help evaluate
important trends through a lens of relevant
technologies in
order to spell out business implications,
large scale social
needs, important trends and so on. Thoughts
to this point, I
want to pause here, thoughts on tech push
versus tech pull.
[Audience]
You can use tech pull to drive major R&D decisions
in an
organization and tech pull lends itself better
to that than
tech push. Tech push deals mostly with what's
out today and
what the emerging - what the trajectories
are of, say, these
[inaudible] materials and so on. Whereas,
tech pull leads
you to think all right, what are some important
emerging
trends and what type of development ad what
sort of future
technology is required for my organization
to avail itself
to those trends.
[Audience]
So technology is so vast that people are - any
technologist
is limited by his or her toolbox. I mean there
are a couple
of things you can do. First of all, you can
hire people who
are intellectual, curious and open to constantly
informing
themselves on all kinds of emerging trends.
So even though
that is by definition I going to be a toolbox,
people who
are extremely focused and committed to a certain
type of
technology or certain type of implementation
are incredibly
important, valuable to any organization. You
need people
like that but they are not good fits for innovation
programs. So the first thing I would say is
just staff
carefully. Staff someone who loves reading
The Economist
magazine, who is always interested in broadly
informing
himself or herself. Also keep your Rolodex
really fat full
of experts. I mean my dirty little secret
is a lot of what I
am able to do is digging to my Rolodex because
I've been at
this for so long. So when someone needs an
expert on RFID
chips, I have got a guy. And when someone
needs someone who
is an expert on artificial intelligence, I
have got someone
else. In every case, what characterizes those
people is they
know how to bring interdisciplinary innovation
teams up to a
shared level of familiarity without bearing
them in
technical detail that they don't understand
anyway. Other
questions?
[Audience]
Yeah, that's a good point. You want to have
wide Rolodex,
yeah. And of course, that's easier and easier
with
information technology these days. But you
still have to
have a right kind of person, a good cultural
fit that can
assist
[inaudible].
[Audience]
Yeah, we are going to cover that in the next
session. Yeah,
that's a very important point because the
businesspeople and
the technical people need to change their
behavior depending
on the themes of the program. Your behavior
is static any
more, then the development phases of the program
are static.
Okay, no other questions, we move on with
that. So I guess
one - here is how I like to think about what
I call the
dynamic role a technologist, and you could
just as easily
call this the dynamic role of a businessperson.
Because a
lot of you are interested in leadership, some
of you are
already in leadership, in many cases, you
are going to be
managing heavily technical teams. Something
that has been
difficult for me and that has been a personal
transformation
for me, and that is incumbent on many of the
technologists
is what is to adjust your behavior, your patterns
of
behavior, what you say and what you do, depending
on the
phase of the program. How many of your are
engineers in the
room? How many of you have an engineering
background? Who
saw the Tacoma Narrows video? Can you describe
it to
everybody?
[Audience]
Yeah,
I mean the bridge is completed, and it goes
crashing
into this canyon below, it tears - yeah, and
the rebar gets
torn open and things like that. So basically,
all engineers
have seen this video, and the message behind
this video is
don't let this happen to you. Be conservative;
be risk
diverse; be safe, use safety margins. And
that's exactly as
it should be. When you are in the development
program, the
development stage of a program. If I am driving
over a
bridge with my family, I want it to be just
having been
designed by a professional engineer with large
safety
margins. When I carry my laptop computer on
to a plane, I
want it to have been designed by someone who
knows how to
treat lithium batteries so that they don't
explode. But
fundamentally, engineering - and I am an electrical
engineer
by training, both undergrad and grad - engineering
is
fundamentally a risk-averse profession, and
that's the issue
that needs to change for a successful and
consistent
innovation. Here is a deal. This is a very
qualitative graph
that I have drawn. These are three major phases
of any
program with the innovation elements highlighted.
What do we
do? We explore, we ideate, and then we develop.
Now, if
these were linear, this is 95% of the project,
this little
block would go like all the way through that
wall to the
outside. But these phases, these early innovation
phases are
desperately important and that's why I wanted
to call them
out. What's important is shown vertically
and quantitatively
here. So what's important when you are doing
development?
What matters is that you don't have another
Tacoma Narrows.
What matters is that your lithium battery
doesn't explode or
that your bridge doesn't fall into the canyon.
So, an
attitude of feasibility and risk mitigation,
which all
engineers are trained in and the field of
tracks people who
are careful and want to mitigate risk, is
of prime
importance during the development phase. If
I come up to
Lewis, and he has got a circuit board that's
almost done,
and it's got a shape, and I say to him, you
know what, I
have just discovered a new chip that I think
would do a
better job for you, and I think you should
switch over to
it. I may be correct factually. It may be
a better chip, it
may be a higher processing power and user
fewer watts. But
it's a stupid thing to say because we are
in development,
and we are going into regulatory testing,
and we have got to
get the thing out in the market in four weeks
or six weeks.
So I am saying a correct thing but at the
wrong time. Now,
let's talk about the inwards of that. This
is where things
really go wrong involving technical people
in innovation
generally, particularly in big companies,
a question came up
around big companies. During the exploration
phase, as if
you are interested in leading innovation,
you have got to
figure out a way for people to extend disbelief
for days or
weeks during the exploration phase, and in
particular you
have got a figure out a way for people to
think about new
technologies, new and emerging technologies
in terms of
inspiration and opportunities, not in terms
of the risks
that they represent. For those of you that
are not
engineers, engineering training, which is
important, is a
great deal if it is around risk mitigation.
If it asks to
deliver something, you pluck out the areas
of risk. If you
are asked to deliver a medical instrument,
you say okay, the
fluid handling system is going to be problematic
and these
sensitive analog electronics are going to
be an issue. I am
going to pluck out those risk areas, and I
am going to worry
about them, and I am going to mitigate the
risks with
analysis and iterative testing and iterative
prototyping.
That's great. That's as it should be. During
the early phase
of a program, you need to figure out a way
for technical
people and technical teams to think about
emerging
technologies in terms of the opportunity and
in terms of the
potential for inspiration of those emerging
technologies,
and not in terms of the risks they represent.
I am talking
about the cultural change here. I am talking
about a
behavioral change that is born of people.
I mean what is
culture? A culture is a result of what people
do and what
they say in a given organization. I am talking
about people
saying different things and doing different
things as
appropriate during different phases of the
program. So the
counter example of what I mentioned - the
sort of
hypothetical I gave with Lewis is this. If
during the
exploration phase, Lewis brings up a really
exciting idea
for a mobile data service, and I say you know
what, there is
a reason that it's never going to work or
the reason it
would just be too expensive to develop, Lewis,
or something
like that. I may be correct, my statement
may be rigorous
and factually correct, but I am saying it
at the wrong time
because what I need to do is create an environment
[inaudible] disbelief is suspended for an
extended amount of
time. If you allow statements like well, we
tried that
before and it doesn't really work, classic
big company
stuff, or that's really risky or hey, you
know, that will
never get through management, those statements
may be but
you can't allow that during the early phases
of a program,
otherwise you will definitely, definitely
squelch
innovation, you will never get any fresh ideas,
and you will
never bring anything disruptive to the market.
And then,
again, qualitatively, in the middle during
ideation, what
you want to manage is essentially equal importance
to both
of these styles of thinking. So for example,
you want to
think about emerging technology or about business
risk in
the case of business to take David's question
from a little
earlier. You want to think about those issues
on one hand in
terms of opportunities and inspiration for
new products and
new services and so on. And on the other hand,
you want to
honestly assess the risks inherent in, say,
the new business
model or latching on to some emerging technology.
So, what
do technologists on innovation team do and
how do they
recommend you manage technologists during
the innovation
phase? Technologists should be helping everybody
on an
interdisciplinary team to understand a broad
aggregation of
emerging technologies. Technologists and businesspeople,
David is a great example, should act as coaches
and teachers
to the team. If they are acting as policemen
during that
early phase, you are in trouble. So when we
developed a
Voice over IP phone for Cisco, I think we
did an extremely
good job of doing two things. One was bringing
the
engineers, the scientists, all the technical
people as well
as the marketing and human factors and businesspeople
out
into the field to meet with a total of about
78 users in
Europe, and Asia, and the U.S. And what I
can honestly say
is that some of the reasons that some emerging
technology
was built into this new phone is because we
created a
careful environment in which disbelief was
suspended during
early phases, and we looked very honestly
at technologies
that, at that point, were still emerging,
like E Ink, the
technology used in a kindle, as kind of the
technologies for
the phone. So, I would like to hear your thoughts
just about
this notion of your responsibility as leaders
to foster a
certain dynamic behavior of technologists,
a behavior that
shifts according to the stage of the program
that you are
in. It's easy to say, it is not an easy thing
to do. Yeah.
[Audience]
Coach and a teacher, yeah, I mean if people
feel like look,
I am going to write the best code in the world
and then hey,
you are a business guy, your job is to put
a price on it and
to manage the marketing activities. That's
okay. But if I am
saying that to you, I am really missing a
trick in terms of
innovation opportunities because if you are
around
familiarizing me with emerging Web 2.0 business
models and
familiarizing me with possible end markets
and new scenarios
of use of whatever technology I am developing
that I never
even thought of, it's going to benefit me.
If I feel like
you are going to create my style, you are
going to be a
policeman, you are going to slow me down,
I am going to
avoid having business people in and I am going
to put
technology on a pedestal and just sort of
blankly assume the
technology will sell itself. Part of the issue
there is
being a T-shaped business person, having an
honesty empathy
and appreciation for the pressures and responsibilities
of
the technical people and part of it is positioning
yourself
from the beginning as a supportive coach and
teacher,
helping them to do their jobs better and get
it right the
first time. Other questions?
Audience
To development resources, excellent development
resources
come on the late part of that curve. You typically
bring
them in when development is happening. But
other resources
can come in really early and my recommendation
is there is
unique answer for every organization, but
my recommendation
here is every company should have a strategy
for innovation
and I mentioned it's
[inaudible]. There are only three ways to
innovate. You can
in-source innovation, right. For those who
did watch GE,
like when it was six years ago, when Immelt
took over, one
of the major incidents he had was to shift
the innovation
process to try to pump up internal and organic
processes for
innovation. So how you are going to innovate?
You can in-
source, you can outsource or you can hire
companies like us
or McKenzie or someone like that to come up
with creative
solutions for you, and you can buy innovation,
you can
aquire innovation, Cisco style, it's a very-very
successful
model. You can acquire, you can license, you
can purchase.
So that's it for innovation and what I would
say is we would
have to get into the specifics of your business
to
understand when it's appropriate to bring
in external
resources, but it should be guided by a set
of strategic
principles around how you want to innovate,
right. And I
consider every single one of these fair game
and I can point
to companies that are extremely successful,
being 90%, any
one of these. I can point to companies that
do most of their
innovations through in-sourcing and through
internal growth,
that outsource most of their innovation to
design firms and
that innovate essentially by acquisitions
and allow small
companies to take the innovation risk, they
are all good
workable models.
[Audience]
Yeah, you lead by example and you create a
culture and if
they are qualitative or worse for the right
kind of
behavior. I mean I think you just need to
look at simple
economic style incentives, it's not literally
payment, they
are intangible incentives. But I think you
just need to look
at the fact that, I think you just need to
consider, I mean
if you are me, you consider that human beings
are entities
that respond to incentives. And if the incentives
are there
for a particular type of behavior, you are
going to get it,
they are going to tell you at
[inaudible] the incentives are there for well
appropriate,
extended suspension of disbelief. And if you
come off as a
cynic and a naysayer, in some organizations
you come up
smart. A hardcore technical organization,
lots of PhDs built
around academic rigor, PhDs from a culture
of peer review at
universities. If you can spear someone else's
idea and show
why it's wrong, you win, okay. That's important
idea, that
comes into it, criticism comes into it, but
if you behave
the way at the wrong time, no one is going
to want you in a
project at IDO, so you get your measure for,
you get your
reward to a great extent. And so you can start
by setting
the right example of yourself as members of
leadership in
organizations. What else can I tell you about?
Okay, I want to talk a little about Synthesis,
this is the
third point that David want to make sure that
all he came
away with because he thought it was an interesting
thing
that he had learned. So let's talk about inspiration
and
let's talk about managing that inspiration
with a process
called Synthesis. How do you do it? First
of all, it's
important to define terms. I defined innovation
earlier. It'
s kind of weird how many CEOs and executives
talk about
innovations and important plank in their strategy,
but can't
actually define what they mean by innovation.
Similarly, we
have talked about inspiration a lot. We will
be talking
about inspiration in this section. Inspiration
is people or
things or events that influence the mind or
the creative
imagination. That's a very general definition.
That's how we
think of inspiration. They are people, they
are events, they
are things that influence the mind or the
creative
imagination. Now, one of the questions that
came up earlier
was how can you be efficient, how can you
innovate in a
small organization, you got a limited budget,
you are in a
hurry, maybe you are creating a startup in
you spare time
and you have full time job. Here is what I
think you should
keep in mind. If you want to innovate, you
need to be
inspired. Like I mentioned earlier, I know
a guy that comes
up with a cool idea every eight minutes or
whatever, most
people aren't like that, but all of us can
be creative and
innovative if we are inspired. And if the
sources of
inspiration I mentioned earlier, by far the
strongest one
are other human beings, face-to-face contact
with other
human beings. Some of you work in B2C businesses.
Of this
role, a gut level of appreciation for the
needs of diverse
base of customers, not for meeting white papers,
not for
meeting market research, but from getting
out in the field
and understanding how people actually live
and work and play
is terribly important. Some of you work in
B2B environments,
for that, forget the word end-customer or
end-user, think
about your stakeholders. You work for a software
company,
it's a B2B firm, you work for SAP, somebody
like that, fine.
Let's get a visceral, let's get a heartfelt
appreciation for
the needs of the business decision makers
and the technical
decision makers and some of the end users
that are going to
be use our software. In either case, what
you learn out in
the field will surprise you, don't kid yourself
and you know
what really goes on. And the notion here is
very simple. If
we are going to be inspired, let's use our
ability as human
beings to listen to what people have to say
and let's look
at what they do, alright. Let's look at how
they use their
cell phones, let's look at how they interact
with software,
let's look at how they use emergency services
and let's use
those observations of patterns of speech in
[inaudible] behavior to project and imagine
how people are
thinking and how people are feeling. So I
want to
distinguish when you are taking an information
early in an
innovation program, I want to distinguish
between classic
research which is essential and terribly important.
This is
something that David did a wonderful job commissioning
from
two different market research sources at the
beginning of
the program we worked on, that's essential
background for
the team. But I don't think you would say
that it inspired
us, it informed us and it was important for
that reason, but
it didn't inspire us. What inspired us was
getting out into
the field speaking to crafters and seeing
how they use
various types of crafting equipment. So I
will give
everybody a minute to just read this off at
the screen to
drive home the distinction between qualitative
research
intended to inspire and quantitative research
intended to
inform.
Okay. So, what's an example here? Shimano,
a lot of you are
public bikers, Shimano makes really nice hubs
and gear-sets,
a lot of bike parts. Shimano asked us to think
about new
opportunities in biking. And one of the things
we discovered
and when you look back on these things obviously
in
retrospect, you can
[inaudible] quarterback yourself and say,
oh, intuitively
that should have been obvious. We have no
idea how many tens
of millions of Americans there were, who really
want a bike,
they have happy memories of bicycle when they
were kids, but
they are intimated by the state of bicycling
today. They are
intimated when they walk into a bike shop,
they are
intimated by the way the bikes look, the carbon
fiber book
look, looks they are intimated by the ripped
guy in lycra
that's selling them the bikes and they don't
want any part
of it. And so one of the things that came
up was how can we
gain, how can we use needs-based insights
from the field to
come up with a new type of bike. And what
we came up with in
this case is what's called the Coaster Bike.
And I can point
to a lot of simple little observations. This
is an early
sketch of one of the bike seats. People would
say look,
biking seems good, but it really hurts when
I have my wallet
and my cell phone. So we created, I can show
you an idea we
created a bike seat that opens up with just
enough room for
wallet and the cell phone, so you can take
those out of your
pocket and stick in into the bike seats. And
there were
whole of little things like that. The brakes
were not
handbrakes, you just paddled backwards to
brake. There is an
automatic transmission which was Shimano technology
which
adjusts the torque, which adjusts the gear,
the gear ratio
based on torque on the chain and so on. So
the point here
that I want to make is that the Coaster Bikes
which they
came out with were entirely inspired by field
research that
we did. They weren't any white papers or anything
that told
us, hey, there are tens of millions of Americans
that are
intimated by the state of biking and that
want something
simpler. I don't know how we would have to
come to this
observation or to this conclusion without
going out in the
field. So now, let's talk about Synthesis.
This is the last
point that Dave wanted me to make and I wanted
to talk about
how we gather information before I talk about
Synthesis. So,
let's imagine that we have done what I have
described,
right. You have created a small team of T-shaped
people. You
have a voice of the human, you have the voice
of the user,
you have the voice of business or policy and
you have a
voice of technology. You have gone out in
the field, you
have read some white papers, you have talked
to experts, you
have done some field research. And again to
the question
that came up earlier about innovating on limited
means, this
can be done very quickly and very inexpensively,
I am not
talking about commissioning six months of
research. The
types of activities I am talking about here
take weeks, not
months. What's next? The next thing to do
is to use your
inspiration to visualize possibilities and
that's the idea
of Synthesis. So here is the premise. If we
want to
innovate, if we want to come up with something
new, we are
going to take in a lot of concrete data. So
if this is time
and this is relatively more concrete information
and this is
more abstract. We are going to take in a lot
of data, some
of it is intended to inspire, some of it is
intended to do
inform, whatever the case, it's about your
tangible inputs.
What do we want to come out with? We want
to come out with
concepts that win in the market.
People misapply
quantitative needs based user research, of
the sort that I
described a little earlier. You need to be
careful of this.
People draw a short circuit from here to here.
I guarantee
you it won't work. If Louise is trying to
come up with a new
software package for the medical instruments
that his
company is developing, if he asks stakeholders
what they
need and one person says, well I need a different
kind of
home screen and someone else says, I need
this sort of
button, if he takes that stuff literally,
these inputs
literally and he just uses them to create
an engineer
requirements spec and implements them, things
aren't going
to work. You must veer into a layer of abstraction
in order
to innovate successfully
and that's what Synthesis is.
Synthesis says, let's take all the inputs
that we have been
gained in trying to understand what the opportunities
are
like. And you are doing your job right if
you get divergent
inputs. If one person says this home screen
is too
complicated and the other says, it's too simple,
it needs
more features, you are doing your job, right,
because you
are finding these irreconcilable differences
and it's going
to be your job to reconcile them and to find
a happy medium
between them. So here are the inputs. The
process of
Synthesis leads to insights, which in turn,
leads to design
principles, which in turn, leads to concepts.
What are some
examples of each of these? The insights that
David and I put
together and the rest of the team on this
crafting project
were this, we created some personas, who are
amalgams of
some of the most common and consisting user
needs that we
saw in the field for five different types
of crafters and we
identified two of those personas as targets
to fairly common
marketing method. We identified two of those
personas as
ideal targets for the organization. The insights
for the
bike project that I showed earlier had to
do with the
hesitation that so many Americans felt about
biking. From
the insights, you come up with design principles
and then
you know that the concepts that you come up
with have been
guided by a synthesized set of inputs. So
the point of our
talk is about the "how of" innovation how
do you synthesize.
So here we are there are seven of us and we
are trying to
get all of our insights into some kind of
actionable form.
So what's Synthesis, Synthesis says, let's
take all this
input, let's find direction and make meaning
from all this
disparate input that we have got. So I would
tell you
exactly how we do at IDO and obviously, I
am not saying that
you should graph this method into your organization,
but
what you may want to do is take some of the
general
principles and apply them as appropriate.
Take 3-to-5-person
innovation team say everybody in this first
row, we all sit
together having done some field research.
We have read some
whitepapers, we have gone out in the field
and we have
talked to stakeholders, take posted notes,
our goal, other
issues aside at IDO, is to keep them in business
with posted
notes. Each of us writes down key points and
key inputs or
key insights rather from the research that
we have done. So
Dave had met somebody in the field, he writes
down 6, 8, 10
signature details of that individual to help
us understand
who that person is. The single best way to
be inspired is to
meet someone in the field, who is a potential
user of your
product or service. A close second is to have
your colleague
who did the same research, of the same research
plan, tell
you about the person they met, show you a
digital camera
image of who it is and put a bunch of notes
up, in much of
same way that a novelist never gives you a
complete extended
labored picture of a character in a novel.
A novelist gives
you a few carefully chosen key signature details
that add up
to a complete and holistic picture. You want
to try to do
the same thing. You want to try to give the
signature
details of the people that you met, so that
we really
understand who they are, how they are behaving,
what their
motivations are, questions like what are their
attitudes
towards technology, how much media they consume,
these sorts
of things. So step one is absorb the stories
and tell
stories from the field. So in this case, the
six of us say,
we would put posted notes on the wall, we
would cover
potentially all these walls, sharing with
each other who we
saw in the field. It is not a lengthy process.
Next, the
best thing I can tell you and so this is,
look for
repetition. Let's imagine that in aggregate,
this group here
meets 16 people total. How could you possibly
base a major
decision on 16 people? The answer is, you
choose the right
people. You choose a set of attributes that
are important to
you, orthogonal attributes of people. Typical
attributes
might be age or life stage, socio-economic
level, attitudes
towards technology and then you get into more
specifics, are
they heavy media consumers, are they crafters,
do they have
high engagement or low engagement with money,
whatever it
is. And then we will decide that David is
going to go out in
the field that he is going to find a senior
citizen, who has
a lot of knowledge about technology, but very,
very low
engagement with media, that's a rather interesting
profile.
By searching a sufficiently broad set of people,
even if it'
s a rather small number, you would be amazed
how often
qualitative research performed with a thousand
or more
people often bears out the results of qualitative
research.
And I'll tell you that with say 8 or 10 or
16 well-chosen
people, who are orthogonal to each other across
the number
of attributes, they are distinct from each
other around a
number of personal attitudes. I'll tell you
what, if you
have met 12 people in the field and you are
trying to
innovate for them all and you identify a particular
theme or
opportunity or area of interest of say 8 or
9 of those 12,
that is significant, that matters. Forget
the fact that it's
not statistically significant. It's important.
So that's all
to justify step 2, which is identifying patterns.
Next,
extract the key insights. So now we are out
here, now we are
thinking about insights and design principles.
This is
really, really hard, because you feel like
whatever you are
coming the way with is really tried. We did
a project, we
worked for six weeks doing research for South
Korean telecom
called SK Telecom on the use of how mobile
phones could
serve the needs of tourists, pleasure travelers
better. We
did research in Asia, Western Europe, US,
tons of Synthesis.
One of the insights that we presented to them,
we stood up
and said, there is an underserved appetite
for authentic and
personalized travel advice. Of course there
is, what a
ridiculous
[inaudible] thing to say. But the fact is
there were lots of
thinking and lots of interviews and lots of
information
gathering behind that and the insight was
essentially a
headline or the tip of an iceberg to a lot
of knowledge that
had been gained by the team. Last point I
want to make
speaks to decision that came about innovating
in big
companies. Craft your message, it's tempting
to believe that
having done field research and Synthesis and
brainstorming
and identified an exciting direction, it's
tempting to
believe that the IDO will sell itself and
that people will
immediately see the benefits of the idea.
This particularly
happens if you are personally excited about
your idea okay.
Guess what, that doesn't happen and the message
needs to be
crafted in an appropriate way. For what I
am telling you
here PowerPoint is a good message. PowerPoint
is always the
right way to go. So at times you want to pay
a graphic
artist to sketch up a storyboard to describe
the key touch
points of a new service. Sometimes you want
to follow a
quick video to simulate the actual experience
you are
describing, sometimes you want to bring in
someone who is an
expert in Flash, the software to assemble
a simulation. But
just be aware that crafting the message particularly
in a
large company where things have to go through
layer after
layer of management and tollgate review after
tollgate
review. Crafting a message is terribly important.
The last
point I will make quickly is Synthesis needs
very naturally
into brainstorming. I don't think brainstorming
is a very
good idea in the earlier stages of the program,
because you
don't know where the opportunities are yet.
If we are going
to ask 6 to 8 people to get together to brainstorm
and a
brainstorm is structured means of rapid idea
generation, we
want to make sure that we have an appropriate
target. We
want to make sure that we have got a framework
of
opportunities and we have done our needs-based
research, so
we have an idea of where to focus people's
attention. Hey we
want it really to brainstorm on this sort
of next generation
data service, hey we want everybody to focus
on this
approach to clinics in emerging economies,
wherever it is.
One quick example, I mean I couldn't tell
you in 20 years in
IDO, the coolest project I have ever worked
on, but I can
tell you the biggest honor and it was this
for sure. A quick
example of observation leading into Synthesis
was a program
for NASA on how to improve spacesuits. They
called and they
said, can you work with us to help understand
how to improve
space suits for the next generation of Lunar
and Martian
exploration. And I kind of thought, well yeah,
I am willing
to work on that. So I told NASA that the work
had to be done
on our terms, that is, it had to be done using
IDO's
approach to innovation and we needed to speak
to multiple
stakeholders. And just to cut to the chase,
I walked into a
room, it was about this size, and I couldn't
really believe
until I actually showed up that we are able
to coordinate
all this. With the help of leadership at NASA,
we got
astronauts from three generations of space
travel. We got
men who walked on the moon, men who were in
Skylab in the
70s and men and women who had been to the
international
space station. We even got this dapper guy
in his 70s, who
designed the spacesuits for the Apollo astronauts.
He was
the design engineer and his name, true story,
is Joe Kosmo,
so I just love. So this is an example of the
innovation
process in action. Spacesuits are disaster.
When I got into
one, the only thing you can think of when
you get into a
spacesuit is how soon you can get out of the
thing. Picture
a ski boot, not a snowboarding boot, but for
those of you
who have had parallel ski, the ski boot that
doesn't fit you
and it like extend that over your whole body.
It's like the
worst feeling you can possibly imagine. Or
if you wear
contact lenses, imagine a hard contact lens
with a piece of
dust under it, where all you can think about
is getting it
out of your eye. That's how a spacesuit feels.
And just to
cut to the chase, it was a wonderful program,
one of the
things we concluded was that in ten-plus year
timeframe,
material science was still long ways away
from solving the
challenge of creating something was more comfortable,
had
improved situational awareness and was safer
in
consideration of all the things a spacesuit
has to do. It
has to be a pressure vessel, it has to keep
astronauts cool,
when they are in the sun, warm when they in
the shade. It
needs micrometeorite protection. It needs
to provide air and
other nutrients. It has to monitor a lot of
physiological
processes. And through the process of talking
to astronauts
and through the process of brainstorming with
them and being
art-directed by them, the particular insight
in this case
was, we can make some improvements to spacesuits,
but really
the right answer is to create something that
provides a lot
of the most important attributes of a spacesuit
like
situational awareness, but allows astronauts
to work in a
shirt-sleeve environment. So what we came
up with was --
these are some of the early sketches that
we made of a very
small pressurized rover that would allow astronauts
to work
inside of it. It would allow them to slip
in and out of the
spacesuits very, very quickly in ten minutes
rather than an
hour that it takes today. And if you saw some
of those
sketches a second ago, you can see if you
look at the actual
prototype. On the left, it's being presented
to President
Obama's inauguration and on the right, it's
being tested in
Arizona. You can see that the actual prototype
is pretty
close to some of the earliest sketches that
we have made as
a result of brainstorming and Synthesis with
this team of
astronauts. So I am going to stop there. I
would like to
know what questions you have or comments you
have about the
process of Synthesis. Yeah.
[Audience]
So in general, if you are outsourcing professional
services,
the more upstream you are, the more upstream
your
outsourcing activity is, the more what we
call radical
collaboration is essential. So I agree with
that statement,
if the professional services are managed.
If the founders of
a startup commission a market research fund
to identify the
market come up with some concepts and then
come back with "
the answer." And they disappear for six weeks
and come back
with something. I guarantee without knowing
any more
details, I guarantee it will be a failure.
The only way to
outsource successfully on early upstream program
is what we
call Radical Collaboration. And what distinguishes
radical
collaboration from other types of collaboration
is this, in
radical collaboration, innovation programs
shared generative
activities occurred. What that means is that
in the
hypothetical you just gave, the startup identifies
particular points of engagement with the firm
that they have
outsourced some innovation activities too.
They spent a day
with them, two days, three days, at all the
key points. And
if you go on that shared process of discovery,
you are going
to be okay. It's when external entities go
open loop during
early stages that you get in the trouble.
This rule doesn't
apply once you get more into implementation.
You can
successfully create engineering requirement
steps and
detailed specifications, ship those overseas
and gotten very
good code back from peoplem whom we have never
met in,
Bangalore. That's possible once
[inaudible] unambiguous and defined. Early
in the process,
it isn't. So back to specifics, if you think
about these
phases I just described, we always include
our clients going
into the field with us to do the field research.
We include
them and they have what we call a seat at
the Synthesis
table. They are sitting with us in brainstorms.
That's
essential. Other questions?
And I think, well let me just say, of those
terms, I don't
agree with what the gentleman said this morning,
but given
an open move situation where you just commissioned
research
and people walk away and do it, I agree if
you are going
about that way then the founders of the organization
really
need to do it. One last question is --
I think we have a lot of aspiring entrepreneurs
in the
company.
Sure yeah. Do you think?
Yeah I think so. I am wondering if you could
-- the working
at IDO, you are coming from consulting angle.
So the problem
definition in the scope of viewer designed
projects is
essential. I am wondering if you would take
off that IDO
has, only entrepreneur had and you don't have
a client
coming to you, how you would think about scoping
your
project at the start, if it's not
[inaudible]. Did that make sense?
Yeah I would take a cue from venture capitalist.
When you
guys talk to venture capitalist all the time,
every venture
capitalist has a different approach, many
of their
approaches are very divergent. There is only
one thing that
every single VC anywhere in the world agrees
on, which is
this.
So if I take off my IDO hat and I leave IDO
today and
I start a business, I start with a right team,
I start with
an interdisciplinary team of people with a
track record of
success and preferably people who have, if
we are talking
about the startup, people who have provided
returns to
venture capitalists in the past. You got a
team of people
that have two successful startups under their
belt and have
returned handsome returns to venture capitalists
in the
past. That means something about that team
of individuals.
So first of all, you identify a team that
can execute, that'
s fundamental, that's basic, that's table
stakes. I would
happily chose a team of people that can execute
with no
product concept over something with a team
I felt less good
about, but an idea that excited me. Next thing
down right,
you identify the market, let's identify the
right market,
let's a identify market with the right dynamics,
it's got to
be growing and it's got to support, in many
cases it got to
support value pricing. We don't want to enter
something in
commodity. And after that let's think about
the product,
let's think about the concept. Knowing that
most VCs don't
pay that much attention to the concept, they
know the basic
concept, could easily morph 3 or 5 or 7 times
during the
first years of the startups existence but
they are confident
that a good team will get them there, so that's
what I would
do. Other questions?
[Informal Talk]